today it seems like the post and
mid-credits scene for the upcoming Black
Widow movie could have possibly been
leaked this leak comes from somebody who
has claimed to have seen both the mid
and the post credit scene which is why I
say it's a possible leak because it is
in no way confirmed
however the scenes that are described in
this leak do line up with what everybody
is expecting and with some of the leaked
photos that we've seen from the set of
Black Widow so let's go over what these
scenes are and how if they end up being
true how one of them could go on to
affect the MCU in a very important way
introducing a new team so the leak
starts off by saying there are two
scenes a mid and a post-credits scene
which is very typical of Marvel of
course as we all know this is what they
do for the majority of their movies the
mid-credits scene is of yelena Bulova
you see her arrive at a warehouse on a
motorcycle she goes inside and tells
somebody who was off-screen that she got
a device from Natasha the person off
screen is revealed to be taskmaster but
in a different more traditional costume
now it's important to note this part
because from what we've seen of
taskmaster in Black Widow it doesn't
seem like he is going to be wearing the
traditional skull helmet the helmet that
he's wearing in the movie is a little
bit different but if this mid-credits
scene ends up being true that means
they're just saving it for later
but then taskmaster turns around to
speak to somebody and he asks if they've
done enough and general Ross tells them
that they are just getting started now
of course what this scene is going to be
setting up is the Thunderbolts led by of
course Thunderbolt Ross now there's a
good chance that this mid-credits scene
could be true because we have leaked
photos from the set of Black Widow with
Thunderbolt Ross on set so William Hurt
of course who plays Thunderbolt Ross was
literally spotted on the set of Black
Widow and it's been widely expected that
he is going to assemble the Thunderbolts
especially because we know that there's
not going to be another Avengers team
for some time in the MCU so perhaps not
to really take their place but to just
throw another team in there they're
going to put the Thunderbolts in there
to have a team movie and after all we do
pretty much have a full roster for the
Thunderbolts of course we have
Thunderbolt Ross who could be Red Hulk
Yelena Bulova taskmaster Zemo of course
who was making his return in the Falcon
and the Winter Soldier series we have
ghosts from
ant-man and the wasp and of course we
have Justin Hammer so a lineup for the
Thunderbolts is already there and it
seems like if this post-credit scene
really is the post-credits scene for
Black Widow that's what we're going to
be getting in the future of the MCU so
again all the cards are lined up for
them to enter the MCU plus we have those
set photos of William Hurt on set as
Thunderbolt Ross of the Black Widow
movie so there's a high chance that this
could be the post-credits scene but then
we have another scene which is certainly
going to bring back all of the fields
from Avengers in game the scene is of
Hawkeye sitting on his farm with his son
he watches his son play and looks at a
picture of NAT and says to himself that
he misses her now
there's a very specific reason of why
they would make this the post-credits
scene for Black Widow a lot of people
think that Natasha didn't really die in
Avengers endgame or if she did she's
brought back to life some way and
although there is a chance that that
could be possible it's most likely not
Scarlett Johansson herself has stated
that her character Black Widow is dead
and it would be an injustice to her
death if they somehow revived her or
made it to where she actually survived
and for those of you who don't know the
writers actually debated keeping her
alive or killing her but a lot of people
thought that they should have her make
that sacrifice and didn't want to take
it away from her so Natasha Romanov is
gone and the MCU she's dead and that's
what this post credits scene it will say
she's actually gone she's not coming
back she's not going to be in the future
of the MCU it's sad but it is what it is
so drop your thoughts about these post
credits scenes down below also don't
forget to subscribe but with
notifications turned on leave a like on
the video if you enjoyed it and that
enters you in my giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox one or a ps4 and if you'd
like a chance to win an Infinity
Gauntlet go ahead and click the link
down below as always thank you all so
much for watching we'll fluff
you